you
all right let's give the computer
another try here I try the English okay
we're gonna transpose I imagine into a
Queens gambit declined but I'm not gonna
I'm not going to commit my pawn to d4
just yet actually I want to try to avoid
the Benoni d4 c5 computer almost always
gives me no chance or at least that's
how I feel when it's the Benoni
so okay let's try this move order I want
to see d5 before I play my pawn up to d4
okay so my only concern is do I take
first and then push here this is 10 2
game 10 minutes each to second increment
yeah just play here right away keep the
tension okay huh all right well I'm
thinking I want to go right after this
pawn hmm Queen a4 and then just scoop it
up yeah our I mean the other idea is to
play e3 e3 and then Bishop here if I
play e4 it gets a bit too sharp for my
liking especially against computer key
for Bishop b4 and then I have some
concern with e4 pawn push Knight d5 then
I have some concern on c3 on try to
avoid those complications so III or just
a quick queen a4 to c4 I know with this
yeah I want to keep this diagonal open
for my bishop try to get him out to g5
so I better scoop him up right now
before b5 defends my Queen's getting
kicked around hmm b3 or D 3 b3 seems
more natural let's go to b3 and
nights attacked he'll run into a for so
if I play II for right now I think
they'll be be for hmm I also have to be
a bit cautious of this c5 break
definitely this will be happening soon
black will probably have to play b4
first the Bishop g5 and then III or e3
right away I think I want to deploy my
bishop right away I may want to take
here so that after a recaptured this c5
move is a little bit more difficult to
to get in but I still think that this is
right around the corner and I'll have
the bishop get to be 7 this is blacks a
only problem to solve their queen Bishop
it's locked in behind the pawn chain
right now so I'm thinking III let's go
at e3 see anything wrong with it
alright to take or not keep the tension
I'm fine with g5 oh hey v what's the
story with this a4 a3 weakening my dark
squares on the Queen side since he's no
longer gonna be around to defend any of
this
I wonder hmmm I think I need to get
developed let's go with Bishop to e2 I
think yeah let's keep him off of the
default anticipating that this push will
come soon and I don't want my bishop on
this what would then be an open file so
yeah I thought that this might happen
but I thought this is fine as well
definitely don't want to take and okay
let's see what happens and then here no
so this pod needs to move before the c5
move could come hmm what might be a
little bit annoying one day as a knight
getting into b4 not just because it hits
Queen but it can't be kicked away from
that square and it exerts pressure on a
two so one of my pieces will be tied
down to its defense let's go with castle
fully-developed right now and okay my
knight is officially kicked I see
absolutely nothing wrong with just
playing Knight a4 I'm hitting c6 right
now light square bishop exchange hmm
once again one of these situations to
take or not I think the rook is a bit
inconvenienced by being them being on a6
yes it's defending c6 but it's not such
a natural square nothing that's such a
good square here and another thing is
that I may want to hmm I may want to
play this position where I have the two
versus a 19 Bishop I'm thinking about
giving up my bishop for the night
hmm just so I don't have to deal with it
so it's one less tricky night to work
with that's for that's one thing and
maybe I could uh I don't know have like
my night somehow get here one day play
like a good night versus bad Bishop
situation these guys are on dark squares
but if I take the recapture with the
bishop then there's gonna be this e5
break
well maybe not actually if Bishop takes
and then Bishop takes I have Knight c5 I
kind of like that Bishop takes and
Knight takes well there won't be any
fight break I'm gonna go for I'm gonna
try this imbalance so this was my idea
and I should probably follow through
with it right now yeah let's go for it
and oh okay fine no I'm out before hmm I
must say I do like this position right
now I like my position I don't know that
it would really matter which rook I move
I'm tempted to go with the F rook to
have a quick track with my King towards
the center under five minutes hmm and
get to have the Queen's exchanged well
let's go for it I don't think black has
helped at all by me capturing there so
let's go with this get out of any tricky
stuff here and my D is to play rook here
and then okay let's pivot on the c4
square keep pressure on b4 and just look
to double am I not just gonna win that
pawn no
it's not gonna let me do that hmm I'm
gonna play heat no no no no I'm gonna
play here I want to make sure c5 is just
not gonna happen so I did see this that
this move could be prevented but I was
thinking about 91/2 d3 but I don't want
to allow this pawn break just yet I'm
gonna move my knight only when hmm can I
do that I feel like if I offer to draw
it except although it might be giving
some weight to this I don't think it
would it's an accurate assessment if I
offer to draw right now on a decline I
think you'd be giving too much weight to
these guys I'll see how black could be
better here but I'm thinking that I
should only go for 91 to d3 only when
this square is covered by a pawn hmm
time to move the King have to watch over
each - okay and I'm still not gonna move
him just yet I want to make sure there's
no Bishop takes pawn stuff so feeling
pretty cozy here I'll keep my knight
still there I could still work on my
King position and okay I don't know that
I want to go any further I think now's
the time to do what now it's the time to
probably do a knight maneuver this
Knight this pawn right here on f6 was
boxing him out so he could get into a
rook ending I think my knight would be
intolerable on c5 square so I have
pretty good control over this position
so far I do have to be wary of let's say
a rook getting very active one day and
grabbing my a2 pun if I give this check
I don't think I could really make much
progress unless I throw my knight in to
c5 these guys basically offset the
bishop and Knight yeah let's go in this
in for this move right now I don't want
this rook to let's say play here I'm not
sure why that would be so great but okay
take with the pawn of the rook I mean my
first thought is definitely the brook
but is there a way to just take here and
then get the rook into d6 huh that might
not be a bad idea
pawn takes rook here King d3 if ruk d8
rook d1 how are we looking
if the rooks are traded I'm trying to
establish a position where I'm my pawn
here my king on c4 and a very active
rook that way my king could exert
pressure on this pawn
although wait don't I have an easy plan
with rook takes rook bring my King to c4
and bring my rope to a4 and pick up the
b4 pawn hmm under 2-minutes
hmm let's see
Happy New Year by the way it's a January
1st 2015
as my time ticks away pond or rook this
pond is overextended I have to feel like
it is just overextended hmm you know
what I'm fearful of rook takes King here
and then pawn push and then the rook
getting active on the e-file I don't
think it would be so clean let's see oh
nice try once more brooke takes rook i
think this is the last main think of the
game so trying to make it count trying
to make it count
i'm gonna go with this try to get my
king to c4 I don't think about f4 no an
f4 there's g5
let's see hmm
Brookes gonna get active that rook is
definitely gonna get active um still
gonna go for this and pawn push I'm
gonna come back here to defend to
alright and then I'm gonna try to get my
King to c4 oh is the king in a play up
here
no now that's pretty surprising King
here pawn push aha
I missed that um that's why we played
rook c7 King here pawn push pawn push
and then rook here it's happening too
quick just making kind of a passing move
another passing move I don't want to
move my rook what about rook here let's
see what it does it's gonna play with b8
i have it tied down also down on time I
don't know what I want to do I need to
bank some time living on the edge as
usual oh I gotta move quick I want to
open up any other file I don't know that
I can make progress maybe I could come
in here hun push okay let's do this
sneak my king in I got to be careful of
this pond now yeah I gotta get active
here I'm not sure who
benefit with a trade of rooks um
perpetual hmm let's go for this I go
after that pond okay this is getting a
bit messy don't like it I almost lost
track of time let's give some checks is
this the best I could do I want to try
to get active here I'll take this guy
let's give some checks here I got to get
this pawn I got to get this guy for sure
that's a check yeah this looks like it's
gonna head for a draw we'll see it's
offering a draw definitely accept that
because my king is in no way better than
the black king ah I wonder about this
decision here this is my biggest concern
hmm right No excuse me back here yeah
the decision right here to take on to go
into the analysis let's go to the end
here right here to take with the pawn of
the rook tough call for me here let's
see take here hmm it is it's grabbing
some space that's for sure
if King here rook here and if look here
like if I ever crossed there is this
check which is a bit annoying because
then I do this and I don't think the
rook exchanges itself it's it's gonna
play here with the idea where if I
capture well for one I think I'll end up
losing my c5 pawn but the end the other
thing is that this square after this
capture this pawn controls c4 so I can't
even put my King in a position to think
about capturing the pawn on b4 I don't
know I know I spent a lot of time on
that but I
I feel that it was the more a critical
position having a decision there to
change the structure and another thing
is that I kind of in the back of my mind
overlooked that this f4 move could be
met with g5 you know I would really like
to stop this e5 break with f4 but here
comes g5 and this rook will become
active it's not like I'll just haven't
had to have the rook tethered to the
defense of the b4 pond seems like he's
going to get active in some way as an
example if I improved my king position
there's takes only even let's try
something other than that if I take here
there's a recapture like this so there's
gonna be an open F file for the rook to
invade if I go here you know he's he's
just two steps away if I don't have many
two pawns so I have to be careful mm-hmm
it's just not so easy and the other the
other type of pawn transformation would
be let's say after f4 g5 to just keep
these guys sitting after king d3 takes
takes rook here g4 will be met with I
imagine f5 even if I'm losing upon this
rook again is getting super active tough
call I guess it's a fine result though
in the end but yeah I'd like to the the
opening I got here I think this was a
good choice to still go in for to
voluntarily give up my bishop here some
interesting decision points like when
there was the tension with the
LightScribe bishops to take or not when
I was questioned earlier with h6 I
initially backed up but in a more
simplified position where I could try
and work against this backward pawn and
I'd looked more into that Bishop for
Knight exchange but anyhow I'm glad I
got a game in here decent result I guess
to start off the new year and I hope you
guys are watching our having all had a
nice New Year's Eve and
are having a good start to your new year
so I'll catch you in the next video and
as always I hope you got something out
of it take care bye
you